[Musique]
ouais
rien de tel qu'un peu de gymnastique
garder la forme et un bon bain de vapeur
car cela permet de rester les mains
[Musique]
oui mais en suivant ce régime là vous ne
risquez pas de maigrir
résultat au lieu de perdre du poids on
prend des kilos et oui et les
médicaments n'y changeront rien mais bon
[Musique]
et plus elle continue mais sont
incorrigibles segorbe cachent les
pilules pour maigrir
j'aime le chocolat
[Musique]
espérant qu ailleurs les autres seront
plus raisonnables auxquelles appétit
[Musique]
oh les points frais garde mais arrêter
mais ça suffit
[Musique]
après avoir mangé tout ça on se sent un
peu lourd
[Musique]
mais ma parole et d'autres restaurants
aussi les gens mangent trois voix tous
malades il faut faire quelque chose doit
tout à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
commençons par faire disparaître les
pâtisseries
[Musique]
oui et vous goinfrer
regardez vous dans une glace et oui vous
êtes trop énorme à les jetons tout ça
c'est qu'il faut c'est une bonne cure
d'amaigrissement bien serrés et des bals
vapeur bien chaud est ce une
alimentation saine et mes yeux allaient
commencer par des carottes
ne trichez pas ne trichait pas ne
trichez pas allez bon appétit et soyez
raisonnable au revoir à toi tout merci
du coup
oui
et